vendre du rêve c'est fini fini le
traditionnel jeu du marketing elle la
consommation de masse j'ai beaucoup plus
de gens lire les étiquettes lire des
choses comme ça je vois beaucoup plus ça
c'est vrai aujourd'hui les attentes des
consommateurs sont tout autres et moi je
suis pour l'authenticité authenticité le
mot est lâché
et ce marché amène de nouvelles
réflexions avec l'impact écologique on
est amené à se poser les bonnes
questions à vouloir chercher chercher la
qualité et l'engagement écologique on
vient de le dire humains planétaire ou
encore économie
je sais que je vois cette tendance un
petit peu partout sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les discussions certains
sortent sur cette tendance en appelle ça
du rétro marketing faire du neuf avec du
vieux remettre au goût du jour des
produits abandonné depuis longtemps et
ça fonctionne on retrouve des saveurs
des parfums je pense intéressant comme
celle du haricot baran geniez disparu il
ya longtemps est revenu à la vie en
berry cette année l'aboutissement d'un
projet de dix ans comme l'ont constaté
christine launay et philippe roy très
résistant à la sécheresse le haricot
baran jeunes s avère être riche en
antioxydants avec une teneur en
protéines très élevé le groupe isa a
donc décidé de le transformer près de
130 kg ont été récoltés à l'automne
aujourd'hui on est vraiment sur une
phase de découverte où on fait découvrir
le produit hors aux acteurs locaux
que ce soit les élus que ce soit les
restaurateurs et puis les enseignes avec
lesquelles on souhaite travailler ces
produits on peut se les procurer au
jardin d'insertion d'aubigny sur nère en
attendant le développement de leur
production car l'objectif aujourd'hui
pour isa groupe c'est de rapatrier
l'unité de conditionnement de la
légumineuse de nancy vire de berry est
en effet un projet d'unité de production
c'est un projet qui est bien avancé on a
fait l'acquisition d'un terrain
récemment on commence à parler avec les
financeurs pour nous accompagner sur ce
projet là c'est un projet qui devrait
voir le jour sur le territoire de béni
d'ici 3 4 ans avec à la clé environ
combien d'emplois on est parti
aujourd'hui sur la base de 30 à 50
emplois
et si on a l'opportunité donc fait plus
on ne s'en privera bien entendu par
prochain projet de valorisation de
légumes oubliés un coulis de sucrine du
berry il sera commercialisée en début
d'année prochaine
on vient de le voir lunel oui c est
légumes oubliés tous ces aliments
oubliés ils ont diverti simon fabuleuse
pour le corps c'est sûr qu'il ya des
vertus ces aliments ont plus de fibres
si on prend l'exemple parlant des
farines qui sont maintenant très raffiné
et en ce qui concerne les végétaux
sauvages ils ont effectivement beaucoup
nutriments beaucoup de vitamines
beaucoup plus que les légumes qu'on va
retrouver en supermarché c'est évident
est-ce que c'est déjà un business c'est
déjà un business toute façon c'est sûr
que c'est déjà un business mais j'en
veux dire est ce que la fin ne justifie
pas les moyens
alors que certaines personnes se fasse
un business autour de l'écologie de la
bonne alimentation moi ça me pose pas de
problème partir du moment où les gens
mangent mieux où les gens réfléchissent
un peu plus à ce qu'il ya dans leur
assiette
c'est un travail à temps plein pour du
oui c'est un travail à temps plein je
suis auteur et journaliste culinaire
depuis 2006 me suis installé à la
campagne et
ça sonnait comme une évidence il fallait
que je pratique beaucoup plus de
jardinage beaucoup plus de kayes est
donc le retour aux sources couler de
source voilà
nous avons quitté linda louis pour
découvrir une autre recette ancestrale
celle de la fabrication du savon du vrai
savon michel boda on peut le dire comme
ça puisque c'est un retour à
l'authenticité pour vous également
si vous estimez que c'est un retour à
l'authenticité que de venir 200 ans en
arrière
oui d'une certaine manière c'est un
savon quand même différent c'est à dire
que le nôtre peut être acceptée par la
peau alors qu'on estime que les autres
savons ne sont plus totalement
acceptable par la peau si vous faites le
savon réellement comme on le faisait il
ya 200 ans et on va se retrouver avec
une main d'oeuvre qui est non pas
spécialement onéreuse mais c'est de la
main d'oeuvre
ensuite une matière première qui elle
est toujours des huiles végétales de
grande qualité
on va introduire dans le savon et la
réaction cette alchimie qui va faire que
en mélangeant de la soude et du savon et
de l'huile on va créer le savon on va
créer 7 bis et reid
donc cette opération c'est une opération
réellement qui ne peut être que manuel
ce retour à l'authenticité vous le
ressentez depuis des années est ce que
c'est devenu un vrai business
plus les gens reviennent à ce naturel
plus il est à la mode et plus les grands
groupes vont venir s'intéresser et venir
nous mordre les mollets parce que c'est
nous qui représentons aujourd'hui la
plus grande possibilité d'expansion
comme on part de quelque chose de 4 5%
du marché pour le bio 10% aujourd'hui on
a des possibilités d'aix à rien on va
tous les grands groupes racheter des
petits groupes pour devenir bio essai
plus bio que moi tu meurs aujourd'hui la
fabrication authentique des savants les
recettes avec des légumes anciens ou le
retour des gestes ancestraux avec tout
cela nous ne sommes pas seulement dans
le passé puisque ces produits et
savoir-faire ont besoin des nouvelles
technologies comme internet pour
partager conseiller vendre et répondre
aux besoins des clients